hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where us gamespot nerds and you talk
about the shows that we like and today
we're talking about agents of shield
season 4 episode 7 deals with our Devils
[Music]
alright guys we want to get you involved
with our show so we've been looking at
your comments on the last couple of
episodes and we had an objection yeah so
what happened was we saw an early
screener and everyone was correcting us
that the show wouldn't be back next week
so sorry about that oopsy-daisy oops and
we also got another comment from Francis
you who said that Eli will become
molecule man Tony tell us about molecule
man so molecule man there's some
similarities to what happened with Eli's
he was involved in the lab accident got
some weird scars which he lighted
thankfully didn't get but he can control
matter and energy so there's some
similarity he opened up a portal or like
a dimension a rift to another dimension
which that was once your other stuff
were not gonna get into so there could
be some similarities we're not getting
into secret wars beyond her as it's been
proven time and time again with the show
like yeah we do your own thing with the
only thing is molecule man's more of a
fantastic for villain and that's owned
by fox so I don't think they were gonna
go full on merging but like they're
doing with ghosts right I mean they're
mixing and matching comic book origins
which is cool because if you're reading
the comics you're not like well I know
what's gonna happen it's something
different so it could be kind of like
molecule man but one thing that is
confirmed by that is he is definitely
not the comic book eli morrow no yeah he
is not a not infesting his his nephew
and he's not dead he's also not dead
he's that does it well he's what is he
now he's the interdimensional might be
now you [ __ ] you can make carbon well
tell you uh you have any theories buddy
yeah I mean series questions uh so look
like ghost writer a little bit yeah
Ghost Rider Ghost Rider will Robbie yeah
when he's separated from the writer he
starts getting cold faster than
everybody
Fitz is like what what's wrong with you
what are you doing I'm trying to get
abouts like yeah man that was totally
called it's like no seriously I'm
freezing was hatching like die I like
Fitz is used to people being like yeah
that's cold enough that he's like it is
cold that's messed up dude help me so
question is is we're Coulson and Fitz
dealing with something separate from
what what Robbie was dealing with
because he dealt with it a lot faster
was the separation from ghost rider like
killing him like Ken he exists outside
of ghost rider or was he dealing with
the same thing that Fitz and Coulson
were dealing with but which was like
different levels of hell purgatory stuff
they brought up questions about where
the ghosts actually were and why the
ghosts were one semi physical like they
could deal to kill other people what was
going on with that because it seems like
the same thing happened right Fitz and
Coulson all they didn't have the weird
yeah seaweed stuff on their face or
whatever and they also couldn't be heard
so i don't know if it's a theory i
personally think what do you think Tony
what do you think's actually is it
purgatory yeah so it seemed like you
know if you got all a purgatory here's
physical world then here's how so maybe
lucena ghosts were here the other guys
were here yeah but also i heard a
vengeance way down yeah and somewhere
down here but I think also because
Robbie died before he became ghost
writer that's why he was affected so
he's already he's already been through
it all and I hold cuz he's dead I think
he cool cuz you did you are doing
something he needs ghost rider till it
because I think if he Ivers like I'm
done our deal is done ghost her eyes
alright see ya Robbie's dead also the
portal is open and they just came back
from Hell through a portal that is just
open yep like I didn't even think about
that chills right now roll through the
door that is getting some stranger
things vives when I was watching this
and when they first show like the
distorted filter on the same exact area
when I'm Fitz and Coulson where that I'm
like they're in the upside down no no
one caption moving up everything would
have been okay guys exactly and then
there was a portal at the enzyme Saiga
but they didn't steal from it at all
it's completely different of course
let's talk about our moments of the week
so speaking of the portal mine was ADA
building the portal and she's just kind
of doing this and then like and then
they're like is she doing anything
[ __ ] functioning sendo powergloves
just doing nothing so she looks at the
book and she just sees a bunch of binary
and she's like huh very interesting cool
got it just starts building a portal
really awesome super all yeah I like 80
a lot I feel like I don't know what's
gonna happen to her next she did read
the dark hold so what will let me she's
a real hottie yeah she is I was reminded
a little of Ultron so Ultron was created
yet by I Hank Pym in the comics and
Ultron built Jocasta which was another
Android it's getting real nerdy / you
know the circus it's all part of me was
like is ADA building another AI or
something like that or some one of you
two said maybe she's making another
brain that's not a sitting she's next
year I talk about what we think for next
week what was your favorite yeah what
was your face my favorite moment was
Daisy driving the car yeah and she's
driving it cuz obviously she doesn't
drive that off and she drove a band you
know good chugging along in the van now
she's got this charged up car the crab
use anyway and if she's scraping it over
the car will heal I'm like no it's not
gonna kill me
matters not Robbie who first time
everybody that like that car thought
exactly that and robbie says it so
cathartic when he's like let's only when
I'm when I'm with the rider and then
then so what was cool and annoying about
to show us how he kept flipping back and
forth the first we see Daisy driving
then we find out Oh Robbie he's actually
sitting there for his first of all it's
like how could a ghost wouldn't like the
car just go through him how could he sit
and there's some physics ghost physics
temper I don't know what that is go six
thanks Lucy was physics Lucy was able to
move more stuff around yes I do not
object as long as they're not in sight
of humans maybe there's laws maybe
there's rules yeah my favorite moment
was when Mac turned into the rider yep
I've got some anger that was also when
he goes my axes plenty sharp mm-hmm and
a shotgun yeah that's cool alright
predictions for next week guys well
obviously ghost writer and shield have
to team up to defeat the evil Eli hmm so
how will this affect Mac because he had
the writer in him but now he's he looks
a little distraught he looks like he's
been through some stuff but no yeah he's
been through hell but so yeah that was
because he had that picture yeah and
they had to date April 18 2006 I'm
thinking he had a kid and the kid was
killed or died or something like that so
that's what so he has some reason to be
angry which is why ghost writer was so
easily able to take him over or join
with him right so he you know cuz Mac is
a really super nice guy he's got pain he
but he's he's represses holding
something and we don't really know a
whole lot about his past we know he has
a brother but we don't really know much
else so there's gotta be something with
that picture right and what is a
two-building I think that she's building
a brain we talked about this a little
bit earlier I think that she's building
a brain because she got a bunch of
information she got the power gloves
ready she's building either a brain or a
like a digital kind of brain that she's
going to use to like overcome her own
programming
because I think the dark hole is
inherently evil who used the doctor
strange use the dark hold and it screwed
things up I don't think that anything is
anyone anyone is powerful enough to
utilize it without something being
messed up and I think it kind of it's
inspiring her to do something she still
can't hurt people yet but she's going to
use this brain put it in her head and
become super evil yeah this is what
really dangerous for her to be a villain
that they created and now is out of
control hence Ultron maybe she's going
to create a mate oh if she if she can
tell me if she mind bro if she can you
do to evil things cuz their programming
she can make something else that can do
to evil things because it doesn't have
to programming she's like I have to sit
in the closet all the time I want a
friend to hang out with and watch spice
range of things on Netflix yeah be
single forever Oh evil Robo friend evil
and I just gonna be an army it's gonna
be the new launch of artificial
intelligence taking over the world LMK
DS yeah you will like these it was
actually a story arc word evil or an l
md did kind of gain sentence and like
create other LM DS and was like really
bad so maybe they're going there Amy
alright so what do you guys think I want
to know your theories we want to talk
about them on this show so please tell
us any theories any comic references we
might have missed anything that we
messed up please let us know we want to
get you involved so please leave those
in the comments below and we'll talk
about them next time on nerding out and
for all things nerding out stick with
gamespot universe
[Music]